I cling to his reports I cling to his
reports hoping for something positive he
is one of the best and he is is locked
in on what's going on in the lockup
between baseball and its Players
Association he is a senior MLB writer
for ESPN and one of the best reporters
on the market our friend Jeff Passan
back here on the Rich Eisen show Jeffrey
how are you today Richard I am well I'm
hanging in there where do things stand
right now
middle of the day the day after baseball
players said that the commissioner
should tell them where and when and all
he said is I'm not confident anymore
Jeff yeah it was you know a few weeks
ago rich an executive has been around
for a while paraphrasing him here said
to me in order for this thing to live it
needs to die first and I think yesterday
when Rob Manfred did such a stark
about-face from where he was 5 days
earlier when he said unequivocally we're
playing it's a hundred percent and then
saying I'm not confident we're gonna
play I think that was baseball dying
momentarily and it is from everything I
hear from everything I see from
everything I think from the perspective
of just pure straight-up logic it has to
happen there has to be a season at this
point because the alternative of no
season is so catastrophic to the future
of the sport that I just don't think the
people who were in charge would take it
there because they you know we have this
canceled culture right part of canceled
culture is not canceling yourself and
baseball would be inflicting
cancellation on itself by having no
Stephen okay I got a few places I can go
after that why does bass what explain to
me that that concept of why baseball had
to die first to live what why why in the
world would that be a rational thought
process for somebody to tell you when
would this pandemic calls for enough
but trying to live for the fans was what
I think is a totally reasonable question
and I think there's actually a very good
answer to it okay the the conversation
we were having was about the breaking of
norms it was about the the leaking of
letters it was about Rob Manfred acting
in very unwrapped Manfred like ways and
and his thought was this thing is so
screwed up right now we need to get back
to some sort of homeostasis we need to
get back to a place where everybody is
so beaten down by this that you just hit
the reset button and that's what
happened yesterday
I think the reset button got hit I think
the sides have to now and this is a spit
I don't know that it needed to come to a
point where one side or the other you
know hit sale blog org but that was
Major League Baseball yesterday it was a
big bag of fail and I think after that
happened the owners need to look at the
state of the game where they are
ultimately the Shepherd's because they
are the ones who own these franchises
for 10 20 30 50 years at a time and
players on average their careers about
three and a half or four years and as
much as the players associatia as much
as the players are the lifeblood of any
sport I also think that the the amount
of influence that they have is finite
and it depends upon the trajectory of
their careers and the idea that over the
course of these relatively short careers
they can shape the future of baseball
and x-ray is just a false premise it
then fault it then falls on the owners
to be those people who are putting in
the right direction well why aren't they
who's the who's the hard liner that's
got Manfred zero unless Manfred's the
hard liner here telling the owners I got
this I'm a labor lawyer who give me
names you know were the ones that are
saying I think let's not play you know I
think I think I think it's a little bit
of both I I think Rob Bamford has for 25
years now actually been extremely
good at his job for the purposes of what
Major League Baseball owners want and
they wanted to take back power after the
Major League Baseball Players
Association held it for damn near 30
years and I think he's done a good job
of that but there comes a point at which
rich the pendulum just swings too far in
the opposite direction and I think that
is what has happened here you've had
players over the last decade and a half
two decades not get complacent not get
comfortable but get to the point where
these little tiny things that they gave
up started to add up and you've seen
dealings not legally in bad faith not by
the letter of the law but certainly by
the spirit of it by Major League
Baseball you've seen the you know the
emergence of sabermetrics more or less
crushed the the free agent market for
players who were 30 years older and
you've seen service time manipulation
and in the case of Kris Bryant who's a
day short of a year of free agency
earlier than he would have otherwise and
you see these these things that in a
vacuum
individually player by player are small
but collectively have shifted the tide
of the sports so much in favor of the
owners that the players are sitting
there saying all we got to do is find an
idea stick with it
show unanimity and there's great
strength in that and I think they have
actually proven that over the last two
months by sticking with the idea that we
want to get paid our salary we want to
get the full prorated share we're not
going to take pay cuts you do not
privatize games and socialize losses and
we're not going to let you do that and
it put them in a position where
yesterday Rob Manfred put his foot in
his mouth and and really I think
calcified in the public this notion that
when players are saying you tell us when
you tell us we're a very simple and
powerful message and then the
commissioner is saying well we're
actually not going to implement the
season that we have been considering
doing and instead we may just shut this
whole thing down
I mean the the optics of that as as
Manfred himself said yesterday are
disastrous and this was the disaster
falling on major league baseball in one
fell swoop Jeff Passan here on the Rich
Eisen show southern what led Manfred to
have that reversal what why why did he
if he's been saying this whole time and
this negotiation hammer that I can
Institute that we're gonna play baseball
I can institute something why why did he
change the track who told him to change
the track what what what circumstances
changed to make him change that that
that approach Jeff is it agreed yes yeah
I think their Bluff called I think that
I I look at it mathematically rich let's
say that the players so so here's here's
the I want to take a step back here just
to get the whole picture Rob Manfred per
the March 26th agreement between the
parties can set the schedule for the
season at the beginning of the month we
were told Karl Ravager myself about the
league's willingness or desire to set a
shorter schedule which was in line with
the idea that there are a number of
powerful owners out there who want to
play a few games as possible because MLB
says that it's going to lose money when
it plays games so this this guillotine
of a 48 or 50 game schedule hung over
baseball to the point where the MLBPA
just got tired of the league repackaging
a very similar offer three different
times and saying hey we're improving
we're improving but in reality it wasn't
getting anywhere close to the full
pro-rated share that they wanted
so the MLBPA said you know what go ahead
set the season will come and play just
tell us when just tell us where and when
that happened Rob Manfred said well if I
set the season at a short schedule then
the duty that I have to play the fullest
amount of games possible in a schedule
as per that March 26th agreement
is going to look extremely fishy because
our last offer to the players was for 72
games and if over the matter of you know
three days you go from 72 to 48 it's
like are you really trying to play the
fool it's impossible now it's true rich
that there is a caveat to this play the
fullest schedule possible and that
caveat includes health and safety
concerns that caveat includes economic
feasibility but in the end if it was a
short season the MLBPA
was prepared to file a grievance that
the the lead did not uphold its duty to
play the full of season possible and if
you look at that grievance it would
probably be for somewhere in the
neighborhood of a billion dollars and if
you look at it from baseball's
perspective even if the union has only a
25% chance of winning that grievance you
still have to value that grievance at
250 million dollars right but that's
just the way that the math works and in
the idea of having that 250 million
dollar liability right there let alone
the possibility of the billion dollars
on top of that is just too much I think
for the owners to stomach at this point
and when they got their Bluff called the
the reaction from the league was to be
okay well you guys shut down
conversations about reaching a
negotiated agreement on a whole season
why should we talk with you guys why
should we do anything if you're not
willing to talk the problem is that
random to the brick wall of we'll play
anywhere anytime and in the power of
that very simple message from the
players I think Fox MLB in and Rob
Manfred inside of that box said some
things that were just optically
miserable oh boy
Jeff Passan of ESPN here and the
Richards your brother optically
miserable was a grand house a bet it was
a great band optically miserable was a
coup stick so alrighty then what's the
Lyell of it Lyle of it stage yes
optically miserable everybody put your
hands together
so what's the difference is there
between baseball's last offer on how
much grand total dollars that they were
gonna give to the players on a pro-rata
basis and what the players want what's
the difference is it what's 400 million
bucks five hundred million bucks where
are we here I mean how you share it over
30 teams and just get this damn thing
done and move on and say you know what
here's what's happened we we understand
after all this time we understand and
then just eat it eat the PR of it and
then just soak in the ratings what about
that so race week we can look at this
two different ways the first way is that
MLB's last offer maxed out at about 1.5
billion dollars in cash to players if
you take that over a pro-rated basis
that's about sixty full games the ML
BPA's last offer was 489 full games at
pro rata which is about two and a
quarter billion dollars so we're talking
to 750 million dollar gap just in cash
out right I don't think that's the right
way to look at it all right the right
way to look at it is if MLB is claiming
and this I have no way of verifying this
the MLB PA does not believe it's true
but and I'll be as claiming that it's
gonna lose 640 thousand dollars per game
played if you take six hundred forty
thousand dollars times 29 different
games of difference between the 89 that
the PA wants and the 60 that MLB is
willing to play times 15 games a day the
grand total is 278 million four hundred
thousand dollars that's less than ten
million bucks a team right there and
that is a bridgeable gap and one of the
reasons that I have confidence that when
it's all said and done this thing's
probably going to end up in the 70 is
you know sixty five seventy five game
range players getting paid their full
prorated chair expanded playoffs in an
actual season that is far more
representative than a 48 or 50 entities
motive in what's the players role in all
this Jeff in terms of blame because
we're you know we're hearing a lot from
the players calling out Manfred you
heard also Youkilis today give again
because you pointed out I pointed out to
the players have a much more relatable
tell us when and where also honest day's
pay for an honest day's work it may be
much more well compensated than anybody
else's work but everybody can understand
you work you get paid yeah that's it and
it's a much more understandable and then
in light of Rob Manfred also saying
earlier this year referring to the
commissioners trophy a trophy in his
name is a piece of metal and I
understand that that that one could be
taken in various contexts but he did say
those words that he comes across as Cova
pointing out that he he's a a
substandard guardian of the game this
whole thing about Cohen like Kovac shows
you should you place a side labor lawyer
you should be the guardian here let's be
the guardian here but what are the
players role in bringing us to this
brink I let's put it this way I think
when it's all said and done the the
moral right here is with the players but
I also wish that the players from the
start would have gone to MLB and said
we're in the middle of a pandemic right
now we you know we had no idea that on
top of that there was going to be you
know the social unrest that there's been
and just that this country feeling like
it's in an absolutely terrible place but
a pandemic alone let's just get baseball
back on the field people need it people
want it let's let's find a common place
the problem is that commonplace was just
never going to happen until it all fell
apart because you see the offers that
MLB has has put out there I mean first
one you know 30 percent pay cut a
pro-rata second one 25% third one twenty
percent and with the number of games
going down rich you know they turn out
to be very similar offers and it's like
okay are you really moving toward this
place to get back on the field is that
really what you're trying to do now the
first offer from the Players Association
for 114 games and a schedule that's
stretching into potentially December
that was a little outlandish but the
last one for 89 games it was probably a
little too late for that but it wasn't
entirely unreasonable but the problem is
they have just wasted so much time and
we're
now rich is where they should have been
two months ago no damn have baseball
like literally right now we should have
faced no diet that is that that is not a
hot take that is a stone-cold fact that
they screwed up badly and they need to
dig themselves out of their own
screw-ups and get this thing done as
soon as humanly possible to rescue the
damage that they have done to their
sport so now Jeff and the glasses last
thing for you the glass half-full
optimistic person in me sees in the
future I see in the future I I follow
you at Jeff Passan I read your stuff on
espn.com there's a link it's Jeff pass
it's deep dive on how both sides came
together and made the season happen
after all and baseball is back what date
do I read about and then who's that
person in your deep dive where you said
that person called Manford that person
called Tony Clark of The Players
Association and got everybody together
who is that person and what date does it
happen Jeff Passan I think there are two
different tracks this can go down I
think if everybody recognizes the the
horror show that baseball unleashed on
its fan base yesterday that they get
something done in the next 72 hours but
that's that the really optimistic
perspective somebody somebody who's
involved in the negotiation last night
said I think this gets done in ten days
and and I think the the way that looks
is the Players Association after the
letter that they received last night
from dan Halen the Deputy Commissioner
comes back and says okay you know what
if you want to have a negotiated
settlement let's do it at say 82 or 84
games and and I'll be he'll come back
and say no we're gonna do it at 65 games
and then it's just a little bit more
back and forth until they get to that
happy medium
I mean they should just go there right
now but I think the players also
recognize they've got hands they do and
you don't want to overplay it right but
when you have when you have hand you
don't want to fritter it away either so
because there is
advantage in this situation right now
that you know the PA right now does not
want to be the team with a one-goal
advantage in a soccer game that's
pressing ahead late and gives up a break
and and someone scores a breakaway tying
goal like you don't want to be the team
that does that so they need to be
judicious and I think the judicious 'no
siz what's going to make this thing last
a little bit longer than it probably
should so but they're I think so they're
talking right now or just somebody need
to get these two people another no no I
think that I think after yesterday
they're gonna talk I think I think MLB
you know if you look at what Rob Manfred
said yesterday he made mention of paying
the players for pro rata first time he
had publicly acknowledged even that
possibility and and he said so in the
context perhaps I'm doing so over a
shortened season but cats out of the bag
man you know at this point the players
are not taking less than full pro rata
and if you are looked to institute a
season because the potential damages
that could come from a grievance then
you just got a swallow hard and say
we're gonna do this for the sport and
they're going to be plenty of places
where we can get that money back there's
a collective bargaining agreement up in
December 20 or December 1st 2021
there's next year when we have no idea
if fans are going to be in the stands so
we're gonna have to have these same
conversations you know I'm not even
gonna call this taking the El but but
deal with it today understand that in a
year of bad losses they're probably
going to be even worse and and get the
damn sport back on the field like that
is your goal that is not your goal that
is your imperative that is your duty you
are the people who are running the sport
run the damn sport Jeff you the man
thanks as always we'll get you back on
again soon you're always so generous
with your time and your information and
your passions the best really appreciate
it Jeff thank you that's Jeff Passan at
Jeff pass and follow them on Twitter
almost hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here